health experts worry large-scale events
could speed up the spread of the delta
variant
there are multiple state fairs coming up
and
take a look at this video from
lollapalooza in chicago where hundreds
of thousands are attending
what could be the largest public event
since the pandemic began
as charlie demar shows us the music
festival does have
strict covet protocols for safety
i need every single force in this crowd
to attend this year's lollapalooza
fans need more than just a hot ticket i
need a vaccination card in your head
festival attendees must also show proof
of vaccination
or negative covid test within the last
three days
if they didn't have those restrictions
in there i'd be a lot less likely to go
it makes me feel safer the festival
draws around a hundred thousand people
each day
thursday's performers played two tightly
packed crowds
with few masks in sight
eighteen-year-old claire woods has gone
before she's vaccinated
but decided this year didn't feel safe
enough i actually stole my ticket just
due to like health reasons i'm also type
1 diabetic
and i just don't want to get sick
[Applause]
and taking care of yourself chicago
mayor lori lightfoot greenlit the
festival
months ago before the delta variant
fueled a surge of cases
despite criticism she's allowing it to
go on
saying event organizers have taken
necessary precautions
but there have been recent warning signs
at other big events
more than 1 000 covid cases have
reportedly been linked
to a dutch music festival earlier this
month about 20 thousand people attended
with protocol
similar to lollapalooza infectious
diseases specialist dr emily landon
can an event like lalapalooza an event
of this size
happen safely well maybe not this size
right now
there certainly is going to be a time in
the future when we can have hundreds of
thousands of people
but that's not today landon is concerned
about what will happen
when the party's over i'm not so worried
for chicago but i am
really worried for those little towns in
unvaccinated america
that have sent some of their teenagers
to lollapalooza and
could they see a faster bump in their
delta cases because of this
absolutely
now another recent example a rapper who
performed at last week's rolling loud
concert in miami says she's tested
positive
for kovid she's encouraging everyone who
attended that concert
to also get tested and dr emily landon
who you just heard from
she says if you attend lalapalooza this
weekend you should consider yourself
exposed even if vaccinated she's
recommending getting tested about three
to five days
after the event eureka charlie thank you